early on this question only means one
thing what can I get out of you kick her
to the curb and call next what up guys
welcome to the dust Harley things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that we are
going to be notified of my daily videos
guys most importantly like the video
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
um let's try to get to a thousand likes
in the comments okay so today I am going
to be reacting to I think it's a megtow
channel I would suggested I'm new to
this guy um but he is gonna do seven red
flags in women so pull pull up the video
king I also would like King and blessing
and um you guys have to tell me if you
agree or you disagree with the red flag
yeah so I'm gonna go first and I'll say
if I agree or disagree then you guys hi
I'm Paul Elam with an ear for men today
my talk is about seven opportunities for
screening out women whom you might
otherwise allow to enter your life
romantically speaking if you're the
average man that might seem like a
strange concept it is not something that
most parents teach in fact most parents
if they teach their sons anything at all
about sexual survival just tell them
what they must do to attract women and
to take care of them not how to Cull out
undesirables or how to take care of
themselves once they are involved puas
and sexual Gamers put you almost
exclusively on the same path as your
parents and for those who are insecure
enough to have blind gynocentrism and
life on your knees shape the core of
their identity puas and Gamers may
actually have some good advice with that
let's take The Road Less Traveled for
just a few minutes and talk about deal
breakers with the Duds out there there
are plenty of them we will start with
things women communicate to you early on
right after meeting you if any of The
Following comes out of her mouth at the
earliest stages of getting to know each
other she is telling you that if you
stay around you're an idiot this is
where you get to pay heed to something
you've been badgered with all your life
that is listen to the woman listen
closely she's telling you something
every time she talks she says nothing
meaningless and never will all the only
question is whether you will be smart
enough to actually listen okay let's do
this thing here are seven early deal
breakers for someone you think you might
want to be with one she asks you what
kind of car you drive guys she doesn't
know Jack's [__] about cars she's just
sizing you up financially ditch the
[__] and look I get it all women size
up men financially it's part of the
human condition but a more sensible
woman will get to know you and will want
to get to know you before being
concerned about what you drive she will
be patient knowing that she will figure
out along the way whether your provider
material that's a problem too but it
doesn't have to be a deal breaker this
early on however if she's Brazen enough
to be that transparent I agree with that
one you agree yeah cause I'm like I just
think that's a has a girl ever asked you
on a date how much you make that ever
happened I feel like I've heard guys
tell me that and I just think that's
kind of awkward I don't know I've always
been told that's rude interview pat
yourself on the back as she Fades out of
sight she asks you how much money you
make oh my gosh
you should respond to this question with
I don't know how much do you cost
seriously guys only a money-grubbing
skank asks you how much money you make
before she knows your middle name all
right these are basic these are basic so
far besides you agree with this yeah
yeah true women will just ask you what
you do for a living it's the same
question but at least it shows some
intelligence intact perhaps she's smart
enough that she can be trained or
educated out of her hypergamy anything
is possible now down the road if you're
serious about each other and are
discussing the possibility of sharing
life as a team then both of you having
your financial cards on the table may be
a good idea but early on this question
only means one thing what can I get out
of you kick her to the curb and call
next she asks if you want to have
children uh not with her you don't
besides being a big giveaway for her
being a woman who is already calculating
child's support it is also the first
hint that she lives on cluster B Street
near the corner of borderline Avenue no
one and I repeat no one in their right
mind starts talking reproduction in the
first conversation some women
particularly older ones who feel their
use by date slipping into history will
be more prone to this don't excuse them
it is not your fault that they ran off
all the potentially decent fathers while
they were sexually viable don't let them
trick you into the quick knock-up and
court-ordered child support they have
been single all these years for a reason
you don't need to spend time figuring
out what it is to know that your
attention is better placed more on women
who are interested in you instead of
your sperm I would never have thought of
that as a red flag huh guess like on a
first date but shouldn't shouldn't she
ask that eventually if she wants more
kids yeah I mean not right away but she
asks what you want in a woman
yeah right ah this guy's so funny
besides this being nauseatingly cliche
let's go ahead and translate this turn
of a question into what it really means
tell me how I have to act to make you
fall for me even if it looks nothing
like I will actually be in a
relationship with you the best
suggestion I can make is that when a
woman asks you what you want in a woman
tell her your penis if she tries to take
you up yeah I've heard this from guys
they'll say like they date a girl like
three months and she completely changes
who she is and then they're just like
Bamboozled after three months and then
we women wonder why guys are afraid of
commitment well because they'll commit
to one thing and then we'll like be
another later it's it's interesting
hearing this from like a guy's point of
view on it run like hell or if you're
feeling really adventurous tell her you
want a woman who gives good head doesn't
talk too much and turns into a pizza in
a six pack at midnight she probably
won't be insulted and if she is she
won't act like it because she's already
established that she's a shape-shifter
that is just looking for a clue as to
what shape to take in order to sink a
hook in you number five she spends the
better part of her first date telling
you what [__] her exes were well
this is like asking you what kind of car
you drive how much money you make if you
want children what you want in a woman
in one breath
and you should get it in your head right
away if you start seeing this one
regularly she will annoy you by playing
chronic victims so much that she brings
out the worst in you then she will use
that to tell some other schmuck a year
from now on her first date with him what
an [__] you were to her I always
think about this too with women that say
they were abused by their acts you got
to be careful with them because a lot of
them will just call anything abuse but
yeah it's like if you're constantly
dating [__] after [__] after
[__] I don't wanna you might be the
[__] I'm not trying to be rude but it
might be you probability it is not even
a likelihood it is so certain that
Michio Kaku could express it on a
chalkboard with deadly accuracy do
yourself a favor push the jettison
button on this one with extreme
prejudice tell her you'd like to see her
more but the demands of making snuff
movies keep you busy ask her how much
money she makes what kind of cars she
drives and by the way can she pick up
the check for dinner pick your your nose
and study the results at the end of your
finger over your plate of risotto just
do what it takes to make her lose
interest hell tell her you're an MRA if
you have to at any time during her first
100 hours of talking she says the words
I don't need a man the hell she doesn't
in fact well and the crazy thing is we
just we're interviewing construction
workers today men do all of the jobs
that make Society run so how are you
going to say you don't need a man when
they literally do everything hard in
society like the hardest jobs you know
the plumbing the electricity the the
power plants the oil rigs it's like if
women's jobs disappeared tomorrow
society would probably be fine but if
men's jobs disappeared tomorrow it would
be rough out there to she needs men much
more than the women who are secure
enough to not need a man and secure
enough that they don't have to blurt it
out like a butt hurt welfare [__]
trying to make herself look less of a
leech women who brag about not needing
men are the neediest women on the planet
they need men for money for enabling
delusions for the repair
for enabling deletion thing that has
moving parts for someone to blame when
they don't want to own their [__] which
is pretty much any time they are
conscious they need men for all the
wrong reasons and none of the right ones
like a partnership love and a sense of
belonging like I said listen to the
woman if she doesn't need a man and she
feels a need to remind you of that I
agree if she says I don't need a man
she's just a feminist get she's just a
die-hard feminist before she knows
anything about you listen to her then
check your junk then take the
appropriate action and 86 the [__] like
she could transmit an STD with her
breath she tells you she's a feminist I
called this one if I have to explain
this forget everything I've said in this
video so far and rub your scrotum with
meat tenderizer so the blade won't have
to work so hard I can't stand the
thought of that so let's just leave that
one right there guys at least some of
these seven points were intended to be
humorous even if there was some very
real truth in all of them the point here
though is to let men know that
approaching women with the idea that you
will take whoever will take you is for
puas gamers and other losers an attitude
of scarcity and insecurity leads to
really shitty relationships with really
shitty women treat yourself better than
that explore what she has to offer aside
from her looks and her needs if your
investigation into that puts her off
then make that number eight on your list
and call it a day as an activist I get
emails all the time from Men in trouble
all of it seriously I mean all of it
going back to women they chose to invest
in a wager that none of them ever
considered early on that they had to
hold those women to any standards like
most men well and this is why the red
pill is so important is because men are
always told by society that they can't
have standards they can't want a hot
chick they can't want a thin chick they
can't want multiple chicks they can't
want
um a girl with a low body count they
can't want a girl in shape it's like any
they can't want a Christian or whatever
it is whatever standard men's set I
promise to God that feminist will find a
way to shame him for it even they've
shamed guys for just like doing guy
stuff like you know what I thought about
midlife crisis that's when a guy starts
to like get a little money and he kind
of he kind of becomes a kid again but
it's not a bad thing like I just I feel
like whatever guy is something positive
goes for them feminists will always find
a way to shame it they were just happy
that someone they were attracted to
wanted to be with them now look at them
don't be that guy I like this guy he's
funny glad someone sent him to me um let
me know what you guys think in the
comments
um I'm trying to think if there's any
deal breakers that I would add early on
oh chest tattoos do not date a woman
with a chest tattoo let me tell you any
tarot card readers I'll add that on uh
multiple baby fathers red flag right
there
um yeah I I think though those are just
some red flags but let me know what you
guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out uh anything you
would add King any you'd agree with me
on the chest tattoo though right never
date a woman with a chest tattoo
uh like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time